hallo mein name ist luca und draußen
fertigen betonmischer her der mann dass
er um halb zwei mitten in der nacht eine
neue straße anlegen muss halt ich hoffe
man hört das irgendwie nicht allzu
dollar
willkommen zu drei spiele wie minecraft
die erste folge davon oder dass ich das
mal gemacht hatte kam das voll gut bei
euch an deswegen hab ich mir gedacht die
zu drei neue spiele die toll sind das
erste spiel heißt minecraft crêpes also
minecraft scheiße minecraft keystone
okay das heißt wir klicken einfach mal
auf 2d das heißt das level gilt
generiert view 34 jump to much das heiß
gelaufen wie in gottes die laufe ich
versuche mal hier in die höhe was habe
was ist was was soll warum bot was ist
das für ein scheiß spiel gut das heißt
im development oben drin aber das sollte
fünfzehnte erste 2011 das ist
viereinhalb jahre her
in der tat okay wir starten das ganze
mal von vorne 2d jetzt laufen wir mal
eine andere richtung das heißt wenn ich
jetzt hier im laufe bin ich hier was da
ich kann sogar springen müssen
das ist nicht wahr ich verliere leben
ich verliere die ganze zeit dauerhaft
ich bin ich habe keine leben mehr wie
was ist das für ein scheiß machen wir
den baum kaputt kann ich nicht irgendwie
okay ich kann hier weiter laufen und was
hier kommt ist wieder
und damit sind wir auch schon beispiel
zwei angekommen und zwar wie minecraft
quiz das hört sich nicht den spielern
sondern mehr wegen der rechen stunde
oder eine schulstunde oder sonst
minecraft ist markus persson der
korrekte kräfte lämmer ist damit hatte
ich schon immer probleme aber ich glaube
dass warren blöd restart was kann ich
einfach okay ich kann einfach continue
monster scans pollin mushrooms dafür
kann ich ausraste aber damit jeder mal
weiß wem das hat das eure mutter damals
auch mal gemacht also das habe ich jetzt
selber gemacht das sieht man auch schon
daran weil die schriften sogar verdammt
hässlich ist vielleicht nicht meine
mutter damals immer alle möglichen
kleidungsstücke so mit filzstift
reingeschrieben luca so das geld locker
wenn das irgendwie findet zu wenn das
einer cloud oder finde dann jobst sie
noch nicht was da drin steht also
zumindest bei mir hat es nie gejuckt
weil ich habe bisher niemals
zurückbekommen
also noch heißt markus persson das ist
korrekt der lämmer wird so betrachtet
dass es auch korrekt mit dem monster
scans ponys ist falls ist es dann
entsprechend auf korrekt kost roboter
items und kate beide player die truppen
nicht dass auch nicht
es kommt aber darauf an weil wenn ich
die kuh töte wenn ich sie an zündet dann
kann sie auch gebratenes allerdings in
used to the desktops also scheren können
benutzt werden um spinnen weben zu
bekommen ich meine nicht das geht nur
mit schwertern oder wieder was die viele
hunger keulen gibt es in der football
achtest zu wenig neues inventar und 10
sind glaube ich hier ist korrekt ihm ein
diamond unitel eisen korrekt update
feature mpc religious scheiße ich als
williger sollte es eigentlich wissen ich
meine 17 oder ich glaube ein sechster
verdammter crafting recipe for kate ich
meine dauer incorrect bei oklahoma nie
hart du im golden set 50 oder ich würde
sagen 50 das ist auf jeden fall korrekt
homepages can you make 64 444 a bis 1952
fucking basta ich will das nicht mehr
spielen ich will einfach nur mein
ergebnis nachher habe ich will das ist
ja ich hab jetzt hier auf das ist doch
ich kann doch das ist wie will was ist
wie schnell wie lange hat dieses quiz
spiel 3 trägt den namen kate in das ist
ein spiel was sich vorstellt ist das
laut ok how to play brauchen wir nicht
wir drücken einfach auf play und ich
meine ich kann mich jetzt genau ich kann
mich hier ihr hier sind irgendwelche
höhen und ich kann mich irgendwie durch
graben hier ist wasser da ist aber da
ich bin tot
guck mal wie sky live
roger max kohr elf time lord okay das
geht auf jeden fall besser ich meine wir
müssen irgendwelche er zu sammeln und
dürfen dabei nicht irgendwie sterben das
heißt da ist beispielsweise lava das
heißt fließt jetzt eigentlich zu uns in
die da ja als die fusions hin und her
das heißt wir müssen uns hätte als
irgendwas explodiert gerade das heißt
wir mit erwerb ist wer ist da war ihm
eine frau gerade gold ja noch mehr gold
und noch mehr gold und das war schon
wieder irgendwas explodiert ist überall
aber hier ist überall dabei ich bin ich
bin doch das ist doch wieso ist hier
überall lava das kann die ich möchte
einfach nur hier unten neben mir kurz
jedoch dass gold ihr schönen abholen da
ist auch wieder das kann uns als ob ihr
denn überall lava ist the ballad of gay
tony
bald kann ich durch das wasser durch
wenn ich anscheinend nicht ich bin ein
kleiner süßer knabe und ich bin ein
bisschen gold bisschen gold will wieso
explodiert hier mal gold gold gold und
da ist noch mehr gold und dann hole ich
mir hier auch noch das gold und dann
kriege ich hier auch noch das gold und
hier ist ja auch noch ein bisschen gold
das ist ja super die fällt auf alles was
ich schon so halb erkundet habe wird
wieso denn immer explosionen wie macht
das gerade mega angst von unten kommt
lover und von oben kommt wasser
wie soll ich denn da irgendwie in
irgendeiner form überleben ohne dass er
gott oh gott oh gott ganz ganz schnell
ganz ganz schnell hier durch
da freunde das war's mit drei spiele wie
minecraft ich spitze des todes weil sie
einfach heute 40 grad waren wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann zeigt das nur mit
einer bewertung schreibt mir die
kommentare wird irgendein spiel kennt
was die minecraft ist und wer schreibt
einer terraria wollt ihr noch mal eine
folge davon
nein auch okay